Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. Here's
a great question about the origins of anti
Voxer ism.
Take a listen.
Speaker 3: Hi, David.
My name is Caitlin and I'm from Florida.
And I have a question for you about vaccine
hesitancy.
So in rare Florida fashion, I have a mom who
is a Trumper and an anti doctor and happens
to think that since I'm on the premise Froch,
I need to be wary of the market.
The D is getting my blood test with a vaccine.
So obviously she's not very fond of the idea
of getting the urbanizing vaccine, although
the majority of her family members have already
gotten the vaccine and are doing just fine.
So I wanted to know your opinion on where
you think all of this anti-tax sentiment originated,
like is there some point in history where
this kind of became really prevalent in the
United States?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So listen, this is so Mark of the Beast specifically
is a Christian thing.
So so Mark of the Beast is based on particular
Christian teachings.
I don't know what they are.
I don't really care.
But that's that the origin, the first real
big anti vaccine movement was in England around
smallpox.
So you had the anti vaccination leagues.
There were some who had religious objections
to the smallpox vaccine, some who had what
they claimed to be scientific objections,
some had political objections.
And the that that's the origin in England.
Now, in the United States, I believe it was
in the early nineteen hundreds, like nineteen
to nineteen eighty three, there was a smallpox
outbreak and you had the Board of Health in
Cambridge, Massachusetts, mandate vaccination
for all residents.
And some people went absolutely nuts.
And there were similar arguments.
There were so-called medical arguments made.
There were religious arguments made.
There were political freedom arguments made.
So you had that and then you just saw basically
repetitions of that in the mid 70s with the
DTP, diphtheria, tetanus, pertussis, pertussis
vaccine.
You had a similar kind of controversy.
Many of you might remember in the late 90s,
there was the MMR, measles, mumps, rubella
controversy and Dr Andrew Wakefield, who was
disbarred or deported.
I don't know what it would be called, who
claimed that there was a connection between
autism and the MMR vaccine.
So then that built it up further.
And then now the thing now is that it's the
perfect storm because because of the Right-Winger
insanity on covid, you basically weapon not
weaponized, the preexisting ignorance and
conspiracy cism of Trump supporters.
And it's now being applied heavily to the
covid vaccine.
So it's like the perfect storm.
But those are the origins and it goes back
quite a ways and it's absolutely horrifying.
We have a great Bonas show for you today.
I won't even tell you what.
It'll be a surprise.
It's just a great bonus.
Ownership sign up at joint at Kim Dotcom.